we got our bet this week oh yeah oh yeah
how much was it
a grand it was 10. i told you three
grand you're like i would
never bet that i wouldn't throw out
three grand
i lost four grand on the uh i thought
donald trump would win and i
happy birthday to dustin the diamond
poirier as well man you know that all
you need big fight coming up dog
it's gonna be a good one i think it's
gonna be better than people think i do
too it's gonna be a fight fight
that's what i think if he can get
through the first round with connor
hiding that freaking crazy snake
i think he'll he then then it'll be a
good fight the longer it goes better for
your boy yeah dustin
and we'll get in some games and i hope
doesn't i know he watched i hope he
doesn't find it offensive that i bet
against him he knows i love him
i don't think he does at all yeah i i
think he's a math guy he understands
that you got even money when
connor's like minus 320. you gotta take
that better
i think those odds are way off i think
it should be an even money fight
conor hasn't fought a long last time his
last fight was against cowboy
over a year ago an old cowboy dp the
diamond's been [ __ ]
active he's beat some good guys much
better fighter it's an even fight to me
man
really yeah that's the even money fight
it's man it's hard to watch
all of conor's fights and be like man i
would just be it's like fighting a piece
of paper there
you called me because you know you're
not the biggest ufc fan he called me
he's like dog
connor is good i'm like yeah
yeah there's a reason yeah five days ago
he's like man i've been watching this
fight i'm like yes special dude man
when he's locked in special [ __ ] dude
but then it's crazy how
how far away he fights because like he
theo has been watching every fight but
he hasn't seen conor because he's fought
once in the ufc in four years or
something so yeah he's like
the russ might be yeah that's a good
point he [ __ ] up cerrone
so who but when i came in the only time
i got to see him fight was against
cerrone
since then really except for that
mayweather uh fight which he had not
really
translated that doesn't show much but
but still i mean
they fought before i don't know i think
i gotta throw that out that 2014 fight
that don't matter dustin's
so much better talking about a different
fighter that's like watching you stand
up from 2014
and be like man theo's all right like
nah [ __ ] watch this new [ __ ]
right you know like watch if you watch
your old special now that's bad but
compared to what you do now
yeah you're a monster yeah completely
different dude so for dustin poury it's
like 214 dp to now
what what do you think he did what if
you had to give suggestions to dust and
half the time in the middle of the night
i want to [ __ ] send him a bunch of
ideas
but i know he knows it all what do you
think man said
you're a fighter what do you think what
do you think is there a key to doing it
because really diaz has been the only
guy to really be able to do it
yeah i think uh poor that first round be
up be on your toes don't don't get in a
gunfight with him in the first round and
drag it out
if i'm dustin poury i grapple man i
grapple early on because connor's not
known for cardio
so that first round i'd surprise him
trying to take him down and drag him in
the third fourth fifth round
because dustin poirier we know for a
fact third fourth fifth round he's
better
he's beat jo justin gaichy he's eddie
alvarez like he's a [ __ ] as the fight
goes on he gets better yeah conor's
from the g that first second round you
better [ __ ] be ready
because he knocked everybody out in the
first round yeah he's never lost the
first round
never he either knocks him out or beats
him just on the feet oh it's crazy
monster special special dude i couldn't
even make it through foreign woke up
about 15 minutes later
that's why i retired
[Laughter]
[Music]
this game